what up space Fame girls in here from
anime outpro and today I'm going to be
going over every single yonko in history
aka the four Emperors of the sea and
their powers this will be an updated
version since things have changed a lot
since I first made this video over two
and a half years ago and yes I put more
than four in the title because we are
discussing as I mentioned all yonko in
history not just the ones currently
holding the positions as most of us
probably know the Yoko are largely
considered to be the captains of the
four strongest pirate crews in the world
back in the day I would have said the
four strongest living Pirates but with
recent events in the story and I'm
thinking about a certain clown right now
that description just wouldn't be that
accurate if you guys want to see more
updated videos like this one about the
warlord Supernova and more let me know
by Smashing that like button and leaving
a comment if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all let's start with Edward
Newgate AKA white B appeared the man who
was widely known as the strongest man in
the world and the man closest to one
piece after the pirate King's death at
72 years old Whitebeard was one of the
most epic old dudes in anime before his
death in the battle at Marine Fort which
was probably my favorite Arc in all of
One Piece although I must say after what
happened in wano the wano arc is
definitely up there it's worth
mentioning that like two other yonko on
this list Charlotte lindlin and kaido
Whitebeard used to be a member of The
Rock's Pirates they were led by Captain
rocks and they were considered to be the
strongest pirate crew until the rise of
gold D Roger the fact that at 1.3 out of
four of the old era yonko who ruled over
the new world were from the same crew
shows how insanely strong it must have
been at least in regards to raw power
Whitebeard possessed the guragura Nomi
Oda stated that this fruit was the
strongest paramecia fruit sengoku
proclaims at one point that with this
fruit Whitebeard has the power to
destroy the world the power lets
Whitebeard produce shock waves that can
travel through practically anything air
water and land the show Parkways can
cause tsunamis and earthquakes the shock
waves can be unpredictable so allies
have to be cautious around the user and
not get in his way Whitebeard was able
to split an island in half creating a
giant chasm to separate the Pirates on
one side from the Marines on the other
he uses the power to destroy the Navy
headquarters but the power is not
Limitless the Navy has created walls
stronger than steel that won't shatter
as a result of the guragura Nomi power
Whitebeard can create vibrations around
himself to protect himself because of
this ability aokiji can't freeze him
Whitebeard can concentrate his power
into a small orb or a quake bubble
around his hand to increase its power he
can create contained but powerful
explosion type attacks he used this
attack to beat a giant vice admiral with
one blow he destroyed his helmet like it
was nothing he can surround His spear
with a quake bubble and use it to extend
its reach he can mow down enemies far
away in this fashion perhaps the most
interesting power is whitebeard's
ability to grab the air and Pull It by
doing so he tilted the entire
Battlefield at Marine Fort Whitebeard
can also use all three types of hockey
including Armament hockey observation
hockey and the rarest of all conquerors
hockey Armament hockey allows him to
increase his defense and attack and
allows him to injure logia users that
are otherwise immune to physical attacks
observation hockey lets the user send
someone's presence when they are
concealed or far away and can even allow
on to foresee the future to an extent
lastly as mentioned Conker's hockey is
the most rare only one in several
million people have it although it
definitely seems more common nowadays
especially after a while it allows the
user to exert his willpower over others
which can cause people to straight up
faint and animals to run away whoever
possesses conquerors hockey possesses
the attributes of a king so you could
say that they are a born leader when
Whitebeard was younger and stronger his
hockey was strong enough to match that
of the pirate Kings without even
touching the Clash of hockey alone
created insanely strong wins Whitebeard
did eventually die but he remained
standing nonetheless a true boss he was
old and sick so despite how impressive
he was at Marine forward we should keep
in mind that that was not Whitebeard in
his prime and in this update I will
include all the bounties of the ankle
since now thank God we have access to
them all white beards was the highest of
all yako in history at 5.046 billion
before he was taken out it's notable
that if you combined any two yonko on
this list they'd already have a higher
combined Bounty number then Goldie
Rogers Bounty which was
5.5648 billion this gives us a sense of
how strong the yonko are and why they
were considered to be one of the three
great Powers before the warlord system
was abolished they should still be
considered one of the two great Powers
if you ask me anyways Blackbeard stole
whitebeard's overpower devil fruit along
with his title of yonko thus in theory
he can learn to use all of whitebeard's
moves centered around this devil fruit
so this seems like a good time to look
at Marshall D teach AKA Blackbeard and
his powers in more detail next
Blackbeard is easily one of the most
fascinating characters in anime in the
battle at marineford every side seemed
to lose except Blackbeard who managed to
come about as the winner he is 40 years
old after the time Skip and he is the
first person in history to wield two
different devil fruits that's impressive
even before taking into account the
amazing caliber of those two devil
fruits now that he possesses
whitebeard's power to destroy the world
along with his own dark fruit he doesn't
seem that crazy when he says stuff like
I'm invincible and I'm the greatest
after he stole the power from Whitebeard
he proclaimed that his era was beginning
just like rocks had his era and Goldie
Roger had his era Blackbeard is all the
more entertaining because there seems to
be some truth behind his ridiculously
ambitious Proclamation and that becomes
more and more clear as time goes on we
went through the powers of the guragura
no me when we talked about Whitebeard so
let's focus now on the yummy yummy Nomi
aka the dark dark fruit here it is said
to be the most dangerous power in the
history of all devil fruits it's
classified as a logia type fruit and it
lets Blackbeard become a Darkness man
allowing him to create control and
transform into darkness Blackbeard can
use his Darkness power to suck in an
entire town according to Blackbeard his
dark Gravity Power compresses objects
with infinite power and crushes them he
can then release the wreckage from his
Darkness interestingly enough the
darkdog fruit doesn't allow Blackbeard
to avoid damage like other logia users
as he points out the ace the darkness
sucks in everything whether it's punches
blades bullets fire or lightning this
has led me to speculate that it might
not be a logia at all it might actually
be a mythical Zone linked to that theory
in the description however since that is
not confirmed let's just stick with the
logi idea for now his body absorbs all
pain and that pain is even Amplified in
the process but in exchange for that the
dark dark fruit lets him pull in the
actual body of devil fruit users and
when he's touching them he can absorb
their powers so when he punches Ace
while holding him with his other arm Ace
can't use the flame flamethrow to avoid
the attack as we find out during the
battle at Marine Ford Blackbeard can
also absorb down through powers for
himself as we saw when he stole
whitebeard's devil fruit now yes we we
don't know how exactly he absorbed
whitebeard's fruit but since his dark
dark fruit can already suck in devil
fruit users and as I mentioned absorb
their powers temporarily I don't think
it's a stretch to think that his dark
dark fruit power is related to his
unique ability to steal other devil
fruits as well Blackbeard is so powerful
that he actually managed to give the
Yoko Shanks the scars he has over his
left eye and Shanks insists that it
wasn't because he was careless it was
because Blackbeard is that dangerous
Shanks even tells the legend Whitebeard
not to go after Blackbeard because of
how dangerous he is Imagine telling that
to the guy who's called the strongest
man in the world and the one closest to
one piece back when he became a yonko
Blackbeard's Bounty was actually the
lowest of the yonko at
2.2476 billion berries today things have
changed though he now has a bounty of
3.996 billion his new Bounty is only
second to one of the current yonko and
that's Shanks whose Bounty is only a bit
higher as we'll get into later it should
be noted that pre-time skip Blackbeard
was often want to understate and hide
his true power he willingly hid behind
Whitebeard when it suited his purposes
in the old version of my video I
mentioned that Blackbeard's then Bounty
of 2.2 billion although High did not
adequately reflect how dangerous he
actually was and his new updated Bounty
seems to confirm that although I feel
confident that even with his Bounty
being so close to Shanks is already
Blackbeard's only getting started it's
also interesting to note that Blackbeard
even back in the day was powerful enough
to be a commander for the Whitebeard
Pirates even before he had a devil fruit
but he declined preferring to stay
low-key at the time Blackbeard is
confirmed to be able to use Armament and
observation hockey he hasn't been
confirmed to be a Conker's hockey user
yet but I think it's only a matter of
time before it's revealed that he is in
fact a conqueror's hockey user Marco has
stated that Blackbeard's body is odd and
that maybe explains how he could use two
devil fruit Powers at the same time
people say Blackbeard doesn't even sleep
he survived attacks from Ace a
confrontation with Shanks a quake bubble
around his head from Whitebeard and more
and he survived without any significant
and Lasting injuries it's clear that his
body is superhuman however what is
perhaps even more dangerous about him is
his mind his ability to strategize makes
him in my view very dangerous and very
interesting he was able to outsmart
everyone he set up events so that he'd
be able to get the dark dark devil fruit
which he was willing to patiently wait
about two decades for that level of
patience is insane and all that time he
was able to convince everyone that he
was not ambitious at all then he became
a warlord of the sea so that he could
break some ridiculously op people out of
prison and add them to his crew he set
things up so that the Pirates would
fight the Marines while he swooped in to
take whitebeard's devil fruit when the
old man was almost dead he got his way
and he was smart enough to not fight
Shanks when he showed up and ended the
war his mind and Patience are what got
him to this point he's like a chess
master on the world stage and seeing his
plans come together as one of the most
interesting things about the entire
Series in my view he is definitely a
worthy antagonist for Luffy to
eventually face off against most
recently we saw Blackbeard go after or
boa's devil fruit and his Bounty was
already 3.996 billion before he decided
to do this the dark King Rayleigh showed
up and saved boa from Blackbeard but as
usual Blackbeard wins even when he
appears to lose rather than coming up
empty-handed Blackbeard ends up
kidnapping Marine Captain Kobe instead
who's considered to be a marine hero
furthermore the 78 year old Rayleigh
Hypes up Blackbeard by saying that at
his age he couldn't have possibly won
against Blackbeard they were actually
lucky he argues that the particulars of
the situation made it possible for him
to save Boa at all so Blackbeard's
Bounty may go up again real soon after
these recent events and an old Legend
like Rayleigh speaking so highly of
Blackbeard also goes a long way in
hyping up his character he seems to have
come a long way from the guy who needed
to gang up with his crew to finish off
an old injured and sick Whitebeard next
let's look at title of the beasts the
man who was referred to as the strongest
creature in the world his Bounty was
4.6111 billion berries meaning he had
the high highest known Bounty of any
living yonko before he was defeated by
Luffy people often used to say that if
it's a one-on-one battle kaido will win
when Whitebeard was alive kaido actually
tried to attack him but Shanks
interfered clearly kaido was not only
strong but Brave as well brave enough to
go after white beard that is but how
Shanks got him to turn around has yet to
be revealed we'll speculate about it
though when we get to shanks's part so
just wait for that although no one could
say that kaido wasn't strong he
definitely wasn't as good at
strategizing as Blackbeard and so he
never seemed like as much of a threat to
me still he has one of the best
introductions in anime he is introduced
as a man searching for a place to die we
are told that he's been caught by the
Navy or enemy ships no less than 18
times he was tortured time and time
again and lived as a prisoner when they
tried to hang him the Rope snapped when
put under the guillotine the blade
cracked then he attempted to end himself
by jumping off from sky island but he
survived not even kaido could kill kaido
that's how Invincible he seemed and on a
side note I think he's still alive but
more on that later anyways I don't know
if there's been a better introduction to
an OP character than this kaido isn't
strong because he wants to be he
practically views his overpoweredness as
an annoyance at times which is pretty
hilarious he has a reputation for being
unable to die despite his best efforts
the first fight against kairon Luffy was
a significant one we are used to
protagonists fighting struggling But
ultimately overcoming their opponents
however this is not what happens during
this first fight and I'm not saying it's
the first time Oda did this but it's
still noteworthy Luffy hits kaido with
many attacks and kaido is ultimately not
hurt by it then kaido hits Luffy with
his Club once and Luffy is out cold it's
refreshing to see that pure willpower
isn't enough to overpower a strong
opponent sometimes it doesn't happen
often in Shonen manga but kaido was able
to brutally embarrass our Shonen
protagonist and that really showed how
strong and special of an antagonist he
was it took Luffy mastering a higher
level of hockey specifically the ability
to admit hockey rather than just coding
his body in hockey and Awakening his
secret odd fruit to finally beat kaido
and again I don't think Heidel is dead
but he was definitely defeated some
people say kaido took a bunch of damage
beforehand and that's why Luffy won but
the damage he took from the scabbers
Yamato and so on was not significant to
someone as durable as kaido and he still
kept beating Luffy for a long while
until Luffy finally awakened his fruit
point being Luffy deserves the credit
for beating kaido the so-called
strongest creature in the world and the
yonko with the highest Bounty at the
time in a one-on-one fight now let's get
to kaido's devil fruit which is a
mythical Zone type fruit since the last
version of this video we found out its
exact name
aka the fish fish fruit model Azure
dragon as a fish fish fruit it raises
certain questions like was kaido unable
to end himself because he could even
breathe in the sea even if he may have
been paralyzed like other fruit users
also if you didn't know the reason kaido
looks like a dragon despite having a
fish fish fruit is because it's based
off of the Dragon Gate myth where if a
carp made it up a nearly impossible to
climb waterfall it would become a dragon
think Magikarp and Gyarados from Pokemon
because of this myth I think it would be
really cool if kaido had to awaken his
fruit before he could attain the cool
dragon form the fruit as alluded to
allows him to transform into a giant and
I mean giant blue Eastern Dragon he also
has a hybrid form that he seems to use
most often during the course of an
intense battle he can shoot heat blasts
from his Dragon mouth that can cause
devastating damage he can create slices
of wind that can cut off limbs tornadoes
lightning and even hail in the video
games his Ace in the Hole is a technique
that allows him to surround his whole
dragon body in fire so that he melts
everything that comes into contact with
him the only way to beat him in this
case is through hockey Mastery if Luffy
didn't learn to admit his hockey he
would have had to touch kaido with his
final attack in which case he would have
certainly lost due to the intense heat
we also saw kaido clashing with fellow
Yanko big mom as with Luffy they both
use conquerors hockey that rare hockey
that allows the user who possesses the
qualities of a king to exert his
willpower over others as mentioned it
can straight up cause weaker-willed
people to faint or large creatures to
run away Shanks Whitebeard Luffy and
others all also possess conquerors
hockey and in fact the only Yoko that
have yet to be confirmed as Conker's
hockey users are Blackbeard and buggy
and buggy doesn't even necessarily need
to have it since he's not even the
strongest on his crew as we'll get into
but as mentioned I truly believe
Blackbeard has it it just needs to be
revealed still anyways when kaido and
big bomb Clash the heavens split open
just like when Whitebeard and Shanks
clashed that sort of seems like a sign
of Yanko Hood if you will when you can
do that against a fellow Yanko
interestingly enough kaido and big Mom
seem to be pretty evenly mashed in
battle although obviously the battle
could have gone a lot further and they
probably could have tried a lot harder
they eventually decided to team up and
take over the world together after that
they plan to finish their fight to the
death very heartwarming stuff however as
we saw they were defeated by the
combined forces of Luffy law and kid now
next let's look at the 68 year old big
mom AKA Charlotte lindlin The yonko Who
clashed evenly with the strongest
creature in the world at the time and
for a time her own Bounty was 4.388
billion berries but I can't see it
staying the same after her defeat
against law and kid big mom like kaido
definitely doesn't come off as
calculating impatient as Blackbeard she
has been known to destroy entire
countries over sweets almost everyone
including her own children fears her
when she's angry like kaido she was born
powerful rather than trying to become
powerful when she was five she
accidentally killed a large Bear by
smacking it making the Epic takamura
from Hajime and oipo look like a joke
she even broke the bones of a giant by
trying to slap a mosquito like with
kaido her overpoweredness seemed more
like an annoyance than a goal at least
in the beginning even as a kid she could
break a skilled giant sword with her
fist and then defeat him I could keep
going but you get the point she's very
very strong and naturally so her devil
fruit is a paramecia type called
sorosoto No me AKA social fruit the
fruit allows her to take the soul of
whoever she touches and take years away
from their lifespan obviously if she
takes enough years the victim will die
right then and there the ability is
super op but there is a loophole if you
have no fear you will not be affected by
the devil fruit Powers thus if you want
to even hope to stand a chance against
her you better have Mastery over
yourself and your fear she can also put
Souls into inanimate objects or animals
those newly anthropomorphized beings are
known as homies and you can see them all
around total land it's noteworthy that
big mom cannot put Souls into corpses or
other people the fruit can also produce
little incarnations of pure soul that go
around collecting and distributing souls
for big mom big mom used parts of her
own soul to create four special homies
that are far more powerful than the rest
these homies include Zeus the
Thundercloud that is summoned by her
left hand Prometheus the Sun that is
summoned by right hand and Napoleon who
takes the form of big mom's hat the sun
can create Flames the cloud can create
lightning bolts and together they can
manipulate the weather other it should
be noted that recently Zeus who's been
more associate with nami as of late than
big mom has been replaced by a new
Thundercloud homie called Hera thus the
reason I earlier said four special
homies rather than three big mom's hat
can turn into a blade that she can wield
or that can move and attack by itself
her hack can also relay information to
her that it receives from the other
homies homies like clouds can be written
on and allow big mom to travel at high
speeds Prometheus can also engulf
Napoleon in Flames increasing the power
of the sword furthermore the sword can
release powerful destructive shock waves
most recently during her fight against
law and kid she used a year of her own
lifespan to increase her power even
further she gets even bigger more
Godlike as she dominates the panel
compared to the now insect-looking kid
in law it's an Ace in the Hole that she
doesn't use often but as she mentioned
it has been decades since she's felt
pain like the painkit and law delivered
to her so she feels it's warranted she
also uses the master saber combination
of Prometheus Hera and Napoleon in to
create misery and even more powerful
homie the giant powerful creation can
fly around quickly while launching fire
or lightning attacks in short big mom
and her powers are definitely Larger
than Life big mom can also use all three
hockey types conkers hockey arm and
hockey and observation hockey her
Armament hockey could easily withstand
the punch from past Luffy's powerful
fourth gear however the combined
awakened powers of Law and kid were just
too much for her again I don't think
she's dead but she was defeated and in a
sense her fight was less Fair than
kaido's because she was double teamed
while kaido got a one-on-one fight in
the end now let's get to red-haired
Shanks he's definitely one of my
favorite characters and I love the way
Oda has constructed him after the defeat
of big mom and kaido he's the current
yonko with the highest Bounty at
4.0489 billion berries red-haired Shanks
is currently 39 years old in the manga
and he was 27 years old in chapter 1
when the story began he used to be a
member of the Roger Pirates when he was
younger serving under the pirate king
himself what fascinates me the most
about Shanks is how Oda is able to build
so much hype around him without
revealing too much about his powers we
didn't see anything crazy from his 27
year old self although he didn't know
what it was back then we did see him use
Conker's hockey to scare off the Sea
King after it took his arm off later
when we see him approaching Whitebeard
his hockey power is enough to make many
of whitebeard's skilled Pirates pass out
when Whitebeard and Shanks Clash just as
one kaido and big mom Clash they split
the heavens suggesting their
otherworldly level of power then most
recently we saw Admiral greenbull's
reaction to shanks's hockey when
greenbull was set on getting to Luffy
through Momo Yamato and the scabbards it
was shanks's hockey that stopped him
Shanks didn't even have to stop at wano
just being nearby and letting Greenville
sense his conquerors hockey led to Green
Bulls seemingly screaming out in pain
asking who's doing that the red-haired
Pirates are you nearby end quote his
crew even had to tell Shanks to take it
easy since his sudden hockey blast got
the new guys filming from the mouth
Greenville for his part wants none of it
here raises his hands in submission and
says that he's not picking a fight with
Shanks at least not yet and so Shanks
dealt with an admiral an admiral who'd
just been pretty hyped up by just
letting out some hockey from a distance
it doesn't get much more hype than that
now back to the past and I know he was
only 27 at the time and was not as
strong as he is now but still I love how
such a strong dude chose not to
absolutely wreck a weak Bandit after he
spilled a drink in his face here we have
a guy who must be one of the strongest
pirates in the world even at the age of
27 and he let a random Bandit make him
look like a weakling as Luffy put it
even at 27 he had nothing to prove to
anyone he had no ego about the situation
he understood that needless killing
doesn't make you a man just because that
guy threw a drink and Shanks his face it
doesn't mean that he actually heard
Shanks in any way Shanks understood that
one can only be offended if they choose
to be offended and he was above all that
at the young age of 27. truly an amazing
character and role model even at 39
years old Shane Banks was the youngest
your uncle until only recently when
Luffy became a yonku too and I think I
probably speak for most of us when I say
that shank's showing up and putting a
stop to the war at marineford was one of
the most epic and amazing moments in
anime albeit a lot of people were
injured but it's amazing how none of the
Marines or even Blackbeard dared to
challenge him at least not yet as people
keep saying if that doesn't set him up
as being extremely powerful I don't know
what does even before the war he got
kaido to turn back showing that he even
had sway over the so-called strongest
creature in the world and when kaido
briefly thought of the strongest
characters who could challenge him
Shanks was one of the faces who came to
mind along with Odin zebek Whitebeard
and pirate king Goldie Roger if that's
not great company to be in then I don't
know what is it's notable that Shanks
was also the only living one of the five
legends that kaido thought of in my view
when we considered that kaido listened
to Shanks and then turned back that he
places Shanks in the same category as
Goldie Roger and that kaido lost to
Luffy I think that despite the Bounty
difference Shanks is the stronger of the
two his Bounty was just probably lower
because he's much more low-key and even
acts as a go-between at times between
the world government and the pirate
world as we saw at the reverie and let
me just emphasize this it's very
noteworthy that Shanks even as a yonko
could get an audience with the five
Elders who are the public heads of the
Celestial Dragon and world government
that is how much insane sway Shanks
holds over this world we also saw that
near the end of the battle of marineford
he was able to effortlessly stop
sakazuki's punch with his sword and
hockey he also dueled against mihawk the
strongest swordsman in the world before
he lost his arm and not only survived
but made it a fight memorable enough
that not even a legend like Whitebeard
could forget it now we don't know what
exactly happened during their duel slash
duels but I'm one of the few people that
still think mihawk winning makes more
sense since he's the one that holds the
greatest swordsman title after all
perhaps it was a draw but mihawk was the
reigning Champion so he got to keep the
title either way way I feel like most
people underestimate mihawk just saying
but back to Shanks and what's more kaido
has a devil fruit big mom has a devil
fruit Blackbeard has two devil fruits
more recently the devil fruit using
Luffy and buggy became yonko but Shanks
doesn't possess any devil fruit power he
stands alone in this regard this just
makes all of his accomplishments his
hockey Mastery and his reputation seem
all the more impressive so that is what
we know about Shanks not only can he use
all three types of hockey he arguably
has the most powerful hockey in the
series we've never seen him go all out
but that just builds all the more hype
around his character next let's go with
Luffy our protagonist and one of the two
freshest Yanko to hit the scene he
became a Yoko after defeating the
so-called strongest creature in the
world and the yonko with the highest
Bounty at the time kaido I already
mentioned how much kaido was hyped up
during his part remember all of the if
it's a one-on-one bet on kaido stuff and
yet Luffy beat him one-on-one and again
I don't care about all those people
commenting furiously that other
characters heard kaido first because as
I mentioned he was still in great
condition for kaido when he and Luffy
started their solo battle part and he
was even beating Luffy for the majority
of the fight until Luffy awakened his
devil fruit power at this point we found
out that Luffy didn't actually have the
paramecia rubber fruit but the mythical
Zone sun god Nika fruit the five Elders
described the myth of Nika as follows
possessing a body with the properties of
rubber and fighting in whatever way he
fancies bringing smiles to the faces of
the people the warrior of Liberation
also known as Nika the sun god Awakening
brings his rubbery body greater physical
strength and freedom it is said that in
all the world there is no power more
ridiculous end quote this is Luffy's
gear 5 and on a side note if you want to
see a breakdown of all the other gears
we made a video on that specifically
Link in the description but gear 5 is
the big one here that awakened the true
nature of his fruit and helped him to
beat kaido Luffy did many seemingly
impossible things in this form including
stuff like turning into a giant and
using kaido's aforementioned giant
dragon form as a jump rope catching and
launching lightning bolts creating a
fist so big that it made kaido look
small rubberizing and pulling up the
floor beneath himself to reflect kaido's
blast breath back at him and so on in
this form practically anything seems to
be possible like punching an opponent
through the face without killing them
and even grabbing their nose with your
hands that just shot out from inside
your opponent's eyeballs and somehow
your opponent's eyeballs stretch and
revert back to normal by tunifying
himself others and the world around him
Luffy can pretty much do everything you
see in the old Bugs Bunny and Roadrunner
cartoons and keep in mind this was only
the tip of the iceberg we're sure to see
a lot more creative things from this
form which is seemingly only limited by
Luffy's imagination then there's Luffy's
hockey skills it would have made it
clear that although Luffy's devil fruit
is the most ridiculous in the world
devil fruit Powers alone no matter how
special will never be enough to become
pirate king kaido himself pointed out
that hockey is more important so much so
that many of the strongest characters in
the series like Goldie Rogers Shanks and
even mihawk don't even need a devil
fruit power in the end it was Luffy's
Advanced hockey that allowed him to beat
kaido it is because he learned to Omit
hockey that he was able to overcome
kaido's final flame dragon form
otherwise he would have had to make
physical contact to hurt kaido and that
would have just led to the burning and
even melting of Luffy Luffy can use all
types of hockey including Armament
observation and conquerors hockey and
more importantly he's constantly
improving on his hockey skills he's one
of the few people of the already few
conkers hockey users that has learned to
infuse his attacks with conquerors
hockey his hockey Mastery had come to
the point where like the other yonko he
was able to split the heavens during a
clash with kaido suggesting that Luffy's
hockey Mastery is already on the same
level as the strongest pirates in the
world thus Luffy has definitely proven
that he deserves to be a yonko now not
only influence wise but strength wise as
well after he beat kaido his Bounty only
went up to 3 billion barriers he is the
yonko with the lowest Bounty and that
Bounty number is criminally underrated
he has the same Bounty as kid-in-law who
had to work together to beat an arguably
weaker yonko with a lower Bounty than
titles however the story does suggest
that the government is purposely trying
to not make a big deal out of Luffy in
the Public's eye in other words they
don't want the public to focus on him
too much they freaked out when Luffy's
gear 5 picture was printed which proved
that they want to keep The Narrative of
Luffy under control they couldn't not
give Luffy a higher bounty after what he
did but they could spin it as a team
effort one where Luffy is just one of
three up-and-comers and not that special
in and of himself the reason the
government is doing this has been
clearly explained the sun god also
called the worry of Liberation is a
symbol to the oppressed and the more
attention Luffy gets the more likely
people will realize that the Sun God is
real that he has returned and this will
encourage them to rise up against the
oppressive World Government which is the
organization's worst nightmare because
of the unique threats sun god Luffy
poses to the Royal government I think
that if they were being honest Luffy
would have gotten the highest bounty in
history after Awakening his fruit and
defeating the yonko with a 4.611 billion
bounty in a one-on-one fight but moving
on last but not least we have buggy D
clown as I like to call him to be fair
we don't actually know that he's a
member of the D Clan officially so
that's just an unofficial name for now
currently he's being called buggy the
genius Jester and has a higher Bounty
than Luffy currently at 3.189 billion
berries how could he have gotten a
higher Bounty than Luffy you may ask did
he awaken his devil fruit too did he
beat a yonko too nope not at all as
usual buggy stumbles into looking like a
boss this is not to take away from his
natural leader Charisma which is
definitely a strength of his he has a
lot of loyal followers that rally behind
him and look up to him which is very
useful but we can't ignore the fact that
buggy became a Yanko based on incorrect
or misunderstood information because of
the way the cross Guild organization
poster was printed it looked like buggy
was in charge of the dangerous
organization that has done the genius
thing of putting bounties on the heads
of the Marines in reality the
organization is co-led by mihawk and
crocodile but the poster made it seem
like these two legends were working on
their buggy and given the fact that
mihawk has a bounty of 3.59 billion
berries it's easy to understand why
people would assume that his leader
should at least have a bounty of 3.189
billion if anything it's unorthodox that
Buggy's Bounty isn't higher personally I
get why the decision to make bug yayanko
is controversial even though I don't
personally have a problem with it no
matter how you feel though buggy
becoming a yonko changes the meaning and
associations that the word and title
used to have in the series at least for
us readers up to now every yonko was a
beast power wise and crew-wise and
deserved to hold the title but now that
buggy has accidentally stumbled into the
position the title holds less weight
than it did before however if we think
of cross scale built as a yonko force
with mihawk's power crocodile's genius
and Buggy's Charisma then perhaps it
starts to make more sense it can't be
said that buggy is strong as he even
needed crocodile to rescue him from a
vice admiral and he was ready to lick
the boots of crocodile mihawk if it
meant his life being spared so you can't
say he's got that Luffy and Roger energy
either that I sometimes refer to as
pirate king energy however he does have
a devil fruit that would only be fair to
discuss just like we discussed everyone
else's powers he has the chop chop fruit
the fruit that allows him to become a
splitting human he can split his body
into different pieces and control those
pieces most pieces can float or fly too
with the exception of his feet the fruit
does make him immune to slashing attacks
so in a sense he's like the natural
enemy of Swordsmen like mihawk and Zorro
one of Buggy's limitations is that he
can only control his body parts up to a
certain distance but if a body part gets
too far away he won't be able to control
it anymore another weakness is that he
feels what happens to his separated body
parts and that's led him to get tickled
or even hit in the groin while he was
trying to fight with his upper body but
perhaps Buggy's greatest strength so far
has been luck I know luck is weird to
bring up but like King and one punch man
it does seem to be a thing in Shona
manga and we can't deny that buggy has
been very lucky many times he could have
met his end if people like crocodile
didn't show up and help him at the
perfect time it's hard to believe at
this point that buggy won't stumble into
the position of public pirate King 2
even if Luffy ends up being the true
pirate king behind the scenes things
have happened so perfectly in such a way
that buggy really deserves the title of
Yanko in the Public's eye think about it
he was on the pirate King's crew he's
considered to be a brother to yonko
Shanks he is viewed as The Mastermind
behind the prison break at impel down
along with Luffy Whitebeard the
strongest man in the world and the man
closest to one piece asked him to team
up with him at marineford and now they
think he's the leader of an organization
that includes the greatest swordsman in
the world and crocodile not to mention
that this organization did the Insane
game-changing thing of putting bounties
on Marines one of my favorite ideas in
one piece history so that's buggy for
you out of all the yonko he's the only
one not known to use any type of hockey
let alone conquers hockey yet he's
arguably luckier than any other and
definitely one of the most interesting
characters to follow he's a great
example of the fact that even if you're
not physically strong there are many
other strengths you can possess that
could benefit a pirate crew and even
help shape the world anyways that is it
for today's video thanks so much for
watching obviously there is much more to
be said about all these characters so if
you want more details on them check out
my one piece playlist which includes
stuff like an hour-long video on just
Shanks channel the parking within and
smash that like button if you enjoyed
this video If you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates let me know
what video topic you would like to see
next in the comments or if you'd like to
see another updated video on one of the
topics I've already covered in the past
thanks again for watching all the way to
the end to let me know you did watch
until the end until this this moment
drop a buggy is the strongest in the
comments to confuse everybody who didn't
watch the whole video and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys